Here, it's also very high in oxalates.
Yes, and if you have oxalate issues,
that's another thing you just gotta be careful of.
So just because the excursion said
everybody should be doing some carrots,
but ever you see anything that everybody should be doing
that doesn't mean that that's wrong.
I mean, everybody should be trying to eat organic,
but you gotta, it should be a red flag
that you just at least question, right?
So everybody should go on a ketogenic diet
if they have cancer, I don't think so.
So same thing with everybody should use carrots
because they have cancer, I don't think so.
So just question things, you know,
doesn't mean that it's wrong,
doesn't mean it's wrong for you, but just question it.